Nos vimos aquí a falarle de 1 tema tan importante como,
eh, asaude,
2 gallegos y das galegas y boste deben aquí arrirse.
Ustedes ven aquí a reírse.
Esta es
a seriedad ecoa que se toma los gallegos y las galegas,
es 1 falta de respeto
a todas esas personas que están agarrando 1 cita,
que tienen 1 fillo,
1 fillas en pediatra,
o que están esperando por 1 operación.
Postede
no puede traer propuestas de sanidades a a este pleno,
no nos puede traer, porque os EU programa hoy, recortar,
recortar,
recortar, eh, privatizar, privatizar e privatizar,
y por Riva agora
bostedio que está facendo e campaña electoral,
utilizando oseu cargo de Presidente,
utilizando recursos públicos y utilizando a tvga,
de 1 manera que 1 auténtico escándalo democrático.
Non lleváis a colar maíz propaganda,
porque os galegos y galegas están fartos de 1 gobierno
que 1 perigo para su asado. Gracias